before today's video starts I just want
to remind you guys that I'm giving away
my main guitar when I reach 500 000
subscribers please check out the video
in the description to learn more and now
for today's video
[Music]
hey friends in today's video we're going
to talk about tablature whether you're
playing Styles like pop rock or folk the
simplest way to get started on guitar is
to use tablature because it uses lines
representing the strings and numbers
representing the Frets so if you say go
on to the first string and play the
second fret it's very simple it's just
coordinates really it says put your
finger here and now put it here and
because the system is so quick and
intuitive you can get guitarists in one
lesson to learn popular songs
that might be the musical debut of Smoke
on the Water on the loot actually but
classical guitarists don't actually do
this classical guitarists play from
standard notation this is the same
system used by Orchestra players violins
violas oboz pianos Etc and in fact
there's a tendency to look down on
tablature at least by classical
guitarists they think of it as two
simple crude so in this video I like to
debunk that idea by showing you that
tablature was actually the dominant
style of the notation for plucked
instruments like the loot guitar theorbo
and more for more than 400 years so here
is the history of tablature
[Music]
the earliest tablature of which I'm
aware dates from the 15th century in the
beautiful heart-shaped manuscript called
the pesaro manuscript here we can see
six horizontal lines just like in modern
tablature and then letters on those
lines the letters in this case indicate
the the Frets we'll talk more about that
in a little bit so instead of using
numbers like today where if you were on
the first string you could say 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 all the way up in this case it's
just as easy you just swap them up for
letters so a is open B is the first fret
c d e f g
Etc on the fifth line that's the fifth
string C on a loot we see we should play
an A which is open then we see on the
fourth string a c so fourth string a b c
that's the second fret so now we have
two notes at once and then there's a
third note on the third string a b c d
so we have three three notes played
together like a chord in this case this
is a a c g another C it's a an octave
with a fifth in it then we have an open
second string that's a d going to
another chord this time the same chord
is the beginning with a first fret B
that's the tablature B not the note B
which makes the C minor chord so if I
play the opening of the manuscript we'd
hear something like this
with some extra Renaissance style
improvisation it could sound something
like
suddenly we're recreating beautiful
music from the 1400s between 1400 and
1800 there were three main types of
tablets were used for plot instruments
French tablature the system that uses
letters like we saw in the pasaro
manuscript then there's Italian
tablature which uses numbers so modern
guitarists will recognize this one the
only thing for modern guitarists that's
difficult about Italian tablature is
that it's flipped upside down so the
lowest line represents the the highest
string whereas in modern tablature and
in French tablature the the lowest line
represents the lowest string the third
type of tablature is known as German
tablature this is the most different
style of notation in this one rather
than having lines representing strings
and placing notes on those strings we
get an individual symbol for each
location on the fretboard I have many
colleagues who can play from German
tablature so I think it looks more
intimidating than it is this isn't
something that I've spent much time on
yet so I'm going to hold the discussion
about German tab for a future video
the next question people often have is
okay tablet shirt can easily show you
the location of each note on the
fretboard but what about Rhythm well in
tablature the rhythm is written above
the tab in this example from the famous
Baroque guitar piece Canarios by Gaspar
sounds we see a time signature of 6 8
and we see an eighth note written above
then nothing is written until we see
what looks like a quarter note in tablet
for the way it works is you play that
note value for all of the written
pitches until you see a new value so
I've written out in red the explicit
Rhythm above one two three four five six
one two three four five six one and so
it's not until the second complete
measure that we have a quarter note one
two it lasts two eighth notes and then
we go back to eighth notes as we see so
the melody would sound like
as I mentioned tablature wasn't just
used for loot it was used for all sorts
of plucked instruments before 1800 let's
see and hear some tablature from the
past on a variety of instruments here's
the famous La Creme pavon by John
dowland
[Music]
switching instruments here's a
Renaissance guitar that only has four
strings in this case you'll see there's
only four lines for those four strings
foreign
moving to the Baroque loot a 13 course
instrument 13 pairs of strings you'll
still see only six lines but for the
bass strings there'll be symbols or
numbers written below the the lines
representing the low bass notes this is
the beautiful sazonet manuscript
let's see some Italian tab so this is
for fiorbo but now we'll see numbers
instead of letters
and lastly the Baroque tar which has
five pairs of strings so you'll only see
five lines here's a beautiful grave
[Music]
today people like me who specialize in
early plucked instruments instruments
like the loot Baro guitar fiorbo Etc
that we just heard we not only can read
these manuscripts we play directly from
them in concert and I have to tell you
it's a beautiful experience
aesthetically it's wonderful to play
from these ancient manuscripts because I
feel as if it brings me as close as
possible to the composer and I get the
sense when I play from it that I'm not
only just playing from music in a museum
I feel like I'm time traveling 400 years
in the past and playing directly from
the music that a person at the time
would have been looking at
one of my goals in this video is not
only to show you the the wonderful world
of historical tablature but my goal is
also to try to convince many of you
especially you guitarists out there to
learn how to read from these historical
tablatures because as we'll see soon you
can learn a lot from it and you can play
directly from it with a guitar by the
way if you would like one-on-one private
lessons with an expert to help you learn
how to read historical tablature or play
Renaissance or broke music I have an
online school called arpeggianto with
teachers who are experts in their field
who can teach you on Zoom so please head
to rpajonto.com and see if one of my
teachers at my school can be of great
help to you so if you're interested in
improving your guitar playing or
learning a historical instrument or even
just how to play a tab on your guitar
head to rpajato.com so I really hope
this video helped you understand
historical tablature and convince some
of you guitarists to start taking a look
at it and even learn to play from it
next week I'll release part two of this
video on historical tablature and that
video we'll go even deeper into the
subject learning how playing from this
tablature can teach you more about the
composer's intention performance
practice and how you yourself can play
directly from these manuscripts using
your guitar If you enjoyed today's video
make sure you subscribe and hit the Bell
so you don't miss other videos I post
like this one if you want to help me
make more videos like this you can go to
my patreon and there you'll find lots of
behind the scenes content about what I'm
up to the videos I'm making performances
I'm giving and you'll receive rewards
like early viewing all my videos my CDs
and you can even get a private lesson
with me and lastly if you're interested
in learning classical guitar especially
at your own pace at home I have a
beginner online classical guitar course
called classical guitar Pro it's six
hours long 53 videos so I hope you'll
check that out until next time thanks
for watching
foreign